Hmm,
so
this is a fun one.
This is from the ead wind salter,
ninth to twelfth century.
That's how Adam and eve,
but the.
There is speculation that the fruit that
they're eating there,
you see this psilocybin mushrooms,
right?
Because they're the only kind of
mushroom that girl like that.
So that's pretty wild you might say.
And then this is the,
I think it's called [inaudible] steria
vine if I remember correctly,
and it's what Iowasca is made out of and
it has this double helix form which is
very,
very interesting.
And they,
the people that natives,
nobody could figure out how the hell
they made this Iowasca which,
which transports people spiritually in a
very intense manner.
And there's a whole religion based on
it,
like a modern religion as well as the
archaic religion to to,
to make this stuff.
They had to take two plants that don't
grow anywhere near each other and like
there's like a million plants in the
Amazon.
So like how do you figure that out?
Nobody knows.
And then you have to cook them in this
very particular way for a particular
amount of time before you produce this
stuff.
So one of the plants has dmt in it,
which is a very intense psychedelic,
but it's very short acting and the other
has a Mao inhibitor.
So if you take the DMT and you take the
Mao inhibitor,
then the DMT trip lasts for much longer.
And so that's what these Amazonian
natives figured out and no one has any
idea how they managed it and if you ask
them,
they tell you that the plants told them
how to do it,
which isn't much of an explanation as
far as modern people are concerned.
But then when modern people take the
IOWASCA and the plant,
so to speak,
starts to talk to them.
They're a little less leery of the whole
theory that the plants had something to
do with this.
So you know when these things that.
These.
I'm loath to talk about this because I'm
not an advocate for drug use,
but by the same token,
you can't ignore empirical data.
It's not reasonable.
And the empirical data that psychedelic
substances can produce mystical
experiences and that those often have a
transformative effect.
I mean,
one of the latest study showed that if
you took people who were dying of cancer
and you and you gave them silicide,
been in a sufficient dose to produce a
mystical experience that you radically.
It decreased their fear of death.
It's like you gotta think about that,
man.
That's,
that's tough.
That's a tough experiment.
You just wouldn't expect that,
that you think you take someone,
you do range them intensely and then
when they come back they're not.
Even though they're dying,
they're not nearly as afraid of dying,
you know,
you,
you got to kind of wake up and smell the
roses when you see something like that.
And the people who are doing this
research are very reliable people.
So
there's the Amanita Mascara,
you know,
there's this old idea.
It's quite a funny idea.
Toadstools so flies like avenue to
Mascara and there's some.
This is ridiculous.
There's some evidence that they actually
like getting stoned.
So because animals will eat these,
like reindeer will eat these things too.
And they get pretty tripped out by them
and so I have this book on psychedelic
use among animals,
which is a small book,
but.
And so,
so there's,
there's this idea that toads used to sit
around the haven't eaten miscarry and
wait for the stone flies to like buzz
badly around them and then snap them up.
So that's pretty funny I think.
And so,
and you know,
there are mushrooms in the US that are
the oldest,
the oldest organisms on the planet.
Hey,
there's one mushroom,
I can't remember where it is,
but it covers something like,
Oh God,
I don't know,
like square hundreds of square miles.
It's like this huge thing because it's
all underground,
right?
And they have these very complex
networks of mycelium.
They're called and they think the thing
is like 150,000 years old,
something like that.
So there's plenty of things about the
world that we don't know,
that's for sure.